the over consumption of alcohol has long
been recognized as a public health
problem that's why officials in Britain
the U.S and other nations often
encourage people to cut back on their
daily or weekly intake but in Japan the
government has something very different
in mind from Tokyo Lucy Craft has the
story
it's one of the hottest new trends in
Japan bars without booze raising glasses
of non-alcoholic wine these Millennials
say they do enjoy the real thing but
only on special occasions
the student said I'm not worried about
my health but I'd rather spend the money
on nice meals
non-alcohol bars like this one are
starting to take off in Japan popular
especially among younger Japanese and
that's giving the national government a
hangover
with tax revenue from alcoholic
beverages drying up down 30 percent in
recent decades the government launched a
widely mocked campaign seeking ideas on
how to get young Japanese drinking again
the so-called sober curious movement has
stunned officials here where much of
life revolves around drinking
peaking during occasions like cherry
blossom viewing
office drinking parties have long been
considered essential to company team
building the most recent survey from
2016 found Tokyo alone packed with
nearly 30 000 bars and pubs
with over 90 percent of young Japanese
reporting they drink rarely or not at
all even beer Behemoth Asahi has opened
a bar catering to the alcohol averse
nowadays naan or low alcohol beer and
liquor is where the growth is
across town bartender suzumo Sakurai
serves an underserved Market teetotalers
of all ages thirsting for a local pub
without the liquor governments drink
more campaign he said is tone deaf I
think it's a terrible idea he said it's
like trying to get people to smoke more
Japan is a group oriented Society where
getting along has often meant going
along with drinking
consequences visible on trains and city
streets he said Japan has a long
tradition of bonding over alcohol but
people are starting to wise up for CBS
Saturday morning Lucy Craft Tokyo
well the guy on the subway is probably
why people are not drinking it right
these days yeah rough night I'm struck
by the fact that we just did a piece on
how one country can't provide enough
food for people and in other countries
telling them to just drink a ton more
yeah and
right right money is at the root of both
of them one I guess they're the
government wants to make some more money
um folks not having enough of it but you
know it is surprising to see this in
Japan where the drinking culture is so
prevalent but perhaps all these
Millennials have also seen their
families and their parents go out every
single night and not come home and maybe
that's why this is the new change yeah
it's not pretty not pretty sometimes
don't drink too much